going back to uh i think we're talking
about before with uh taxi drivers um
what are like some of the most
interesting clients that you've had yeah
what are the
interesting drivers like before taxi
yeah oh yeah
we're talking about demographics and
[ __ ] yeah yeah so you said you had like
really really like young girls like in
like early 20s yeah you know like people
the audience would kill to drink with
you know
eyes upon
don't mean
the thing is the owner of a um apparel
brand right he knew a lot of models and
stuff oh okay okay yeah so he was really
well versed in the whole you know so he
invited the models to like come together
yeah he would invite us like people he
works with who he works with to the club
and then you know we would have a jolly
good time together
who who were like some of the most like
i guess memorable ones you had
because i'm sure you've met like a a
wide array of like different characters
yeah yeah yeah well honestly the young
girls i'm not really memorable because
at the end of the day if you lived in
japan your whole life i never left the
country
with the lack of life experience there's
not much i can gain out of you
it's mostly me talking about myself and
like you know is the party like that
blah blah but it gets old after a while
right so the best client that i ever had
and i still still do see sometimes to
this day is a very you know senior lady
who is just there for
you know gaining more friends in life
someone who's like above 60
right she doesn't need to do anything
you know she's like sure you know
bentley she comes to the place you know
sure for chafford manor yeah comes in
spends money leaves
but the stories she has
is something yeah you know spending time
with her is you know
that's when i feel like i'm actually
doing something right
so that's what you enjoy about
being host i guess is hearing
interesting stories hearing about life
experience yeah exactly i mean it gets
boring after a while you know just
talking about yourself
oh
a lot of things just fell there yeah so
maybe i jinxed something
i'm sorry my patreon i'm not i i guess
it makes sense right because there's
only so many times where you can tell
your life story and get the same old
it's the goal over and over again right
yeah
i i get that yeah
you know that would get boring what do
you think like makes a like a successful
host then
is it the gimmick do you need like a
unique gimmick to be like a successful
host well looks definitely don't mean
[ __ ] in the crowd
which is weird because you'd think that
that would mean something right
a lot of comments on the youtube video
we're like well some of these guys
aren't beautiful it's like yeah yeah it
doesn't have to be that has like a
surface level value to it like first
impressions impressions yeah but after
that it's all about your demeanor the
way you [ __ ] carry yourself forward
how you present yourself and most people
employ what i guess what i just told you
guys about which is don't talk about
personal stuff yeah compliment them
beautiful eyes whatever
and then try to get them to like you in
that way everybody has their own shtick
yeah to a certain degree so you'd say
like personality is way more important
yeah 100 yeah like in real life yeah
real life holy [ __ ] honestly this is
what where i want to mention my you know
most respected hostel related person
which is dora understand
he's like top of the top so he's not
even a hostel anymore no not anymore
yeah he was
i explain what roland is to the audience
so to those that don't know um please
this is rorando check him out but
to those who don't know rolando started
off as a hosto in his early twenties
[Laughter]
or something you know
you do realize there are people who
listen to audio only right so it's just
like a long pause
okay well then you fill the gap for me
yeah would you do it so like out of
nowhere i was like
oh [ __ ]
okay yeah so roland right yeah so he
started as a normal host yeah he climbed
his way through he went to prachana and
then he went his own club called zakrav
basically man this guy
proved to the world that hosto is not
something that only dumbasses who fail
at life do
it's
what shrewd businessman can do to
leverage their position because he's
like super smart right bro he's he's you
know he's i mean not just like straight
small but he's also like actually
exactly right but the fact that he
always keeps his own hostel values which
is how arrogant he is the way he brings
himself forward like he always knows and
shows that he's the best looking and the
smartest guy in the room right right you
know in japanese culture it's always
about like i don't
you know like
being below the other person being
humble
and then basically like mounts on you
right and like these poor japanese
businessmen they're just like oh my god
they don't know how to handle it
so basically he's a chad yeah he's like
dude
he's a [ __ ] chat he's like a giga
chat yeah i'm surprised you guys didn't
like collab or do anything with him yet
you know
i thought why would he give a [ __ ] yeah
why would he give a [ __ ]
well the thing is you know um divers
flying into the foreign market i mean
i'd like to do something with him
because i've known about him for such a
long time because at one point
especially when he
had just come out of the host business
and like started his own company exactly
like that like he was everywhere on
japanese tv like he was like he's
probably like i would say on in the
grander scale of japanese like
entertainment he's probably the most
well-known host ever absolutely yeah
absolutely so like it was just really
interesting because i i read up on him
as well because i was like who's this
[ __ ] rolling guy yeah and i read up
on him and he's like yeah like you can
tell this guy is just like so [ __ ]
street smart when it comes to like
business and stuff like that and like he
clearly knows his way
on making himself well you gotta be
street smart to be a [ __ ] host right
but like i think as as jan said it
completely flipped
society's impressions of what hosts can
be right yeah right because it's yeah as
you said like to everyone hosts with
just like good looking dudes who have
nowhere to go to like talk about the
jokes for money yeah yeah but like i
think roland completely flipped that
everyone was like no you don't have to
be like that to be a successful host if
anything
doing that doesn't make you successful
exactly and
the most like impressive thing about
roland is the way he approaches you know
his customers yeah as i mentioned my
main impression is through him well i
discovered him after i became a host to
be honest with you but then i discovered
the way i do things similar to him which
is
be hour
well
about yourself because i know for a fact
that within the entire district of
ikebukuro i have more like life
experience
than anybody that you can meet there
yeah but with that as a leverage what i
try to do is
you know levitate the other person
you know i want the the customer to
leave my presence with a feeling of you
know rejuvenation something like
like like all like the ones you're using
i don't know
you
where do you think uh you know life
experience comes from where do you think
you learn life experience
but in general where do you think it
comes from well just tackling new
activities in different places with
people we have never met before
like if you stayed in japan your whole
life never left the [ __ ] you know
neighborhood versus someone who's
traveled the world especially like if
you live in the you know vicinity of
europe
yeah you can't just go to like 20
different countries yeah yeah yeah like
easily that's the good thing about
europe yeah exactly for me because like
to me the concept of driving to another
country is so boy because like japan you
can't do that australia you surely can't
do that i can't even drive to the next
state
right so it's like it's so cool to think
that
in such a small space there are so many
cultures right so i've always been
jealous of like especially you guys like
like the fact that you guys lived in the
uk and like you know didn't explore all
of europe i was like a lot of europe
yeah yeah what's your favorite european
but i feel that's the way to do it
though austria austria austria is like
chill germany
[Music]
i'm sure the germans will be thrilled to
hear that
the german germans know they love their
rules
westeros got like everything that
germany has but it's like
where's your favorite that's not turkey
oh man czech republic
man like it's middle of europe germany
like berlin is like five hour bus away
so you can you know techno clubs
whatever in the uk right people are just
obsessed with getting cheap holidays
mm-hmm yeah so
so i ended up going to like really odd
places that you would like never go to
for any normal reason because someone
was like we're having a wedding there
like i went to malta i was probably like
the four malta viewers who are watching
this
cheap holiday right
it's like it's a really cool place yeah
yeah it is why would you like yeah
you go to a travel agent sometimes in
england and they just they just like
they're uncertainty
we have a country yeah
there's a deal going on there's a good
deal going on in this country right now
so you know i feel that i went to i
think that's the best though right yeah
cyprus because those aren't countries
that
fake turkey
well cyprus's history is like half half
greek it's half germany
i feel like there's some beef going on
there they attack you guys yeah we
should probably cut that one out no
that's fine they'll understand i don't
understand we [ __ ] on countries all the
time okay that's your beef right yeah
yeah yeah yeah you're the one that said
not ass well i'm turkish that's why
you're turkish so it's it's all good
yeah this race if i say it it's just
like so just look forward to a lot of
people from cyprus coming into your chat
to just remind you of what you come to
my twitch stream just to [ __ ] on me guys
let's go no but like that's the thing
right it's like i that's what i like
about europe though is because there's
like the countries that everyone knows
that everyone wants to go to italy
france spain you know the ones that you
think of when you think europe yeah but
then you realize that there are so much
more and even these tiny countries
there's so much like unique culture yeah
just within that so it's like for me
it's like i want to try and go to as
much of europe as i possibly can problem
is my entire life it's been on the other
side of the [ __ ] world yeah it's it's
like the grass is greener on the green
on the other side right because for me i
never fully took advantage of that
because i was like so obsessed with
exploring asia i i just loved like
exploring asian countries that i just
didn't realize what the [ __ ] was in my
backyard my entire life yeah yeah like
my parents fought like took me like i
have a choice but i probably wouldn't
have gone i would have definitely gone
to asia or america right right because
like for me i grew up and i'm just like
oh mom and dad are we going on holiday
oh is it is it thailand again oh we're
we're gonna see grandma again for like
the uh so you know the the 20th time in
my life yeah for me like being 20 years
old so you know
i feel like that was like holidays for
me yeah that makes sense yeah but like
getting back to what where where did we
get to the [ __ ] host thing i guess
[ __ ] so you were talking about the the
very rich 60 year old uh bougie oh yeah
man like
honestly like i don't know if she will
ever watch this but
what i really like about her is
how seductive she is and
in the way she just like conducts
herself like
i feel that was a better choice there to
be honest
she is though
she was just she would just ask me like
hey john how was your day but like the
way she does it yeah the way she moves
her body the way she has eye contact
like she's just it's like someone who's
aware of every single like muscle
movement in their body
you know and like i just watch her and
just like melt away you know i'm like
keep talking to me please and that's too
fair i guess six-year-old japanese women
look a lot younger than six that is true
sixty-year-old six year old japanese
women can look 30 she looks magnificent
like you would
you would barely think she's over 35.
she's turned on the host
and she would always come in trippy
she's pretty eyes
she's beautiful she's actually beautiful
she's she's not going to tell her is
that what you tell her obviously i
always always tell her like you know but
clearly he actually feels that way yeah
just you know like since she i also
respect her a lot because of her
experiences in general you know she has
a lot to talk about but also the fact
that she's such a self-aware person
who's able to make me feel the way i do
that's something you know it's stuff
like that that you know the idol girls
can't do you know yeah i speak to these
girls and i just feel like wow you're
[ __ ] stupid aren't you
that's just the truth though sometimes
when you're speaking and
i mean you must have met some really
stupid girls if you're saying that
stupid i mean you've met a lot of stupid
people out of there yeah okay so like
your level of stupid must be like really
really stupid okay
all sorts of different people i realize
that came out very wrong he saved it at
a lab yeah yeah i'm not calling jan
stupid i would like to say we do not
have our mans right now yeah
this is not ours oh guys
i'm in the corner over here i'm back
into it i'm literally backed into a
corner
just like the you know [ __ ] black
hole spin in the interstellar yeah
i pulled out
a night out with a bro and you're just
like you know what if you're doing this
i'm sorry man i don't have your back man
sorry i'm going to the toilet
of this one you know there are sometimes
you're like yeah got your back anything
you do joey sometimes just like yeah i
was getting ready to call my you know
taxi driver home yeah yeah
so please anything but the tax credit i
rather you call the cia